good afternoon and hello again I've had
the pleasure of getting to know a little
bit uh actually the first thing I had
asked was how she should be addressed a
general doctor but she said for the
purpose of this interview I can call her
Rana so I got that over with I
fascinating life history which has led
to some real insights into health
wellness and and and data but just to
give you a little the the background as
many of you may know it was a prettier
general who was in the Army during the
first Gulf War was in a Blackhawk Isaiah
she was a surgery was exact title flight
search flight surgeon exactly shut down
and was a poww and her experience during
that that episode which she says left
her unscarred because of some mental
techniques that she has both studied and
perfected led to her starting a program
called the comprehensive soldier fitness
initiative which was really not just
about the physical fitness in
preparation and sort of exercises for
the soldiers but also the psychological
preparedness for basically experiencing
stressful situations without leaving
that without having to become traumatic
and this this experience was an
incredible success it created in 2008
and was based on the universe of Pendor
pens fan resilience / research on the
psychological health of students but now
12,000 people in the army have have
participated in this so a 2.3 million
have thought of taking the assessment
and 12,000 our trainers are doing what's
called master resilience training in
February she left the military and is
now working with a company called tech
works but really thinking about how to
apply this to the rest of us and and and
both companies schools and and beyond so
with that with that background let me
just start with the whole concept of how
you came to the notion that that that
that stressful situations that injuries
etc didn't have to be traumas and what
do you mean by by trauma innocent well
from my standpoint it has to do with the
post traumatic stress which people have
you know that the literature is exploded
about that I had had a number of what I
suppose would have been considered
potentially traumatic experiences and I
never felt any of those things I was
supposed to have gotten so so personally
I and I wasn't a psychologist I just
seemed like that that there was an
incongruity there so because people kept
asking since 91 you know what's wrong
with you and I swell nothing that I can
find so so luckily there was a whole
science about about positive psychology
and post-traumatic growth versus
post-traumatic stress and and and I was
very fortunate that it's a chief of
staff of the army at the same time that
there was sort of this explosion of of
problems because I whether the stress of
the wars or whatever I got to the
position where I could help him
implement a a strategy to do some
psychological fitness training prior to
being exposed to a potentially adverse
situation and and so we used adjust as
the model as for physical training and
for those of you who've ever run a race
and I there's one really famous race guy
here i would say um i would say that
that everyone would agree that the time
to train for the race is not after you
have run it and yet we had all of these
programs for people after they've came
back from a deployment and nothing for
before there was a there was an issue so
i said just you know we need to prepare
people before they face some challenge
and it doesn't really matter what the
challenge is whether it's whether it's
combat or it's a divorce or it's
answer or it's a car wreck or whatever
it is the techniques for dealing with
challenges are pretty similar you use
the phrase post-traumatic growth which i
think is profound and the notion that an
adverse event doesn't have to be
traumatic let's go back into your buy
into your bio and talk a little bit
about what you learn from this is your
shot down you are you are shot you will
have broken bones you are abused week
later you're rescued I guess to use if
Reed can you talk a little bit about
just what what did you learn from that
one experience well I've I learned how
important for example I mean I came out
a better patient a better doctor a
better parent I think better leader and
but I realized that a lot of people
think you that something bad happens to
you and and that the only possible
outcome was something negative and and
yes I did get I did get shot I broke
both my arms my leg and so it never even
crossed my mind that that I was going to
be permanently damaged by that no it is
true I can't do as many pushups as I
once could i'm guessing that at 57 most
people can't do as many pushups as they
once could no i don't know that i could
have if I hadn't been shot in the
shoulder I remember that when I was a
kid that the notion of military fitness
being a kind of a model but I think was
a Canadian Australian you know guide was
all about jumping jacks and things like
that so we get that but we don't think
of the military's being a place for
psychological fitness I'm you started as
a urologist and then you pivoted to the
psychological component can you describe
a little bit of the psychology of a new
recruit you know did it take it take an
average an average recruit I know you
talked to hundreds of 9,000 the
thousands of not more of them what what
do you say how do you teach a 17 18 I
guess where they be older the 18 19
year-old to prepare themselves to turn
an injury into a growth experience well
we don't start there we start with you
know how to communicate better and how
to make better decisions and how to look
at what happens realistically instead of
catastrophic Lee and it can be as
something as simple as one
every recruit has to do successfully
before they can graduate is go through
the gas chamber and in every class
there's some number of people who just
are paralyzed in activity and you and it
used to be before we had this kind of
training that the drill sergeant would
basically just scream at the guy until
he either peed in his pants in my home
or or went into the thing we have
learned a better technique that gets
more people through and which is so tell
us why you are afraid to go in and they
will list you know i'm i think i'm going
to die i won't be up my mask won't go
nod will be locked you know and so then
we say okay well first of all is let's
look at the evidence there's no lock on
the door you can't get locked in you
have used the last 12 times you had to
put your gas mask on you did it in the
right number of seconds and and lastly
the gas we're using is not you know it's
it's unpleasant with your icing but it
won't kill you and so applying evidence
to unreason peers is much more effective
than just screaming at somebody we threw
it down a little bit more on that on
that set example so there's two people
you need to teach her there's the
recruit and then there's the drill
sergeant for lack of it so I fan movies
and then the drill sergeants the ones in
the movies are basically going to shout
at you is there a situation where a you
taught them not to shout and beat that
this person can ask for this specialty
recruit can ask the special treatment a
way that isn't personally embarrassing
and humiliating no but what we do have
now is essentially every drill sergeant
goes through the master resilience
training program after graduating from
drill sergeant school because everybody
recognizes that the old thing you saw in
the movies was really not very effective
and so they're pulled aside in some
private place where they can have a know
some often you'll people are perfectly
willing to have this conversation in
front of their platoon you know they're
obviously unwilling to go through it's
all in there you're at the top of the 40
foot tower and you're afraid to let go
and come down and there's no shouting
well there's no screaming you might have
to shout so they can hear you there's no
berating i think is perhaps a better way
okay a kind ler gentler it is a little
bigger and gentler but it's more
effective yeah that you know being
effective is key here so let's now pivot
you left in
februari and you're now thinking about
applying this in the in other settings
when you think about the most analogous
civilian setting for the kind of
practices and techniques that you use
what comes immediately mine where do you
think it would be applying the first
well I certainly think that the best
place to apply it would be in school
that it was the program that was built
for schools we adapted it for the
military bicycles you mean university
university's high school the new school
mmm that's where all the data was
derived it shows these things are
effective so that would be the best
place to go to do it as opposed to do it
but do it deliberately and ubiquitously
don't do it as a big project you know
one school system per state because
because those are the kids I mean the
only reason we're doing in the Army is
those are skills that kids didn't learn
before they came yeah and and not that
every kid some come kids actually have
them they have lots of self confidence
they have lots of self-efficacy they
have lots of empathy they have self
regulation but if they can't talk about
it then they can't help spread it to
their peers or their subordinates either
you have to be if you want to teach it
you have to be able to articulate it so
we have tons of training in schools
about drugs and sex mental thing but
scope but you know I would say the
schools full trauma you would say it's
full of adverse event but any buds
everything when bullying to test dress
etc how who should when should this
conversation happen who should be giving
the parent thing attention parenting
would be a good place and one of the
beauties one of the great things is that
is that we when we teach this to
soldiers most soldiers are parents and
the first place they may actually use
this as a home they try it out on their
families before they're you know willing
to try it at work and they have met with
such great success that most of them
were then move on so well I just had the
best conversation my kid I've ever had
so this might actually work ok so the
parenting and by the way I think you
mentioned there's a book that parents or
anybody could use it was called the
resilience factor resilience factor
Karen drive at shoes that is a primary
trainer from from the pen program it's
her she's the author and it's it's
excellent and I recommend every parent
read it
now let's turn to the teachers in the
curriculum and you know the more formal
institutions how does your out you know
your equivalent army program get
implemented for example high school well
I think it would be guidance counselors
and and whoever is a homeroom teacher
probably would be a good way to start
coaches would be a good place to start i
mean i think we all recognize that that
success is is probably fifty percent
matter you know mental not just muscles
and cardiovascular systems we you know
with the theme of the conference in mind
one of the things we were talking about
it's really is quite striking it is
measurement and and data the military
for all sorts of reasons has incredible
amounts of data both because they you
know they have a kind of a fixed fixed
cohort they they drug testing and
physical testing all this kind of stuff
and also because i guess they have to do
it right everyone there has to comply
and yet and yet they don't do much with
the data what you know when you think
about measurements analytics diagnostics
and then action upon that what what do
you think about the opportunities both
within the military and then it may take
those lessons out here civilian space
well i think it's really important to
measure because what I have found is
that we we have historically measured
the success of something by compliance
with it not by whether it had the
desired effect and so as you mentioned
about schools you have anti-drug
anti-sex anti-bully anti you have anti
and discipline of every sort and I'm
guessing that the school measures their
success by weather every student got it
not whether every student stopped doing
it the army in the military does the
same kind of thing we measure we measure
success historically by what percentage
of the population was exposed to the
training not whether it had this
artifact so we were committed to not
doing that again so we deployed an
assessment the global assessment tool a
self-report survey of psychological
health in the you know emotional social
family there's home and and so then
measured the effect of having masters
news trainers and units by looking at
the change in the GAT scores and
subsequent years and so we showed not
only what percentage of people
participated but that there was a
statistically significant
provement in you know in some important
things positive coping adaptive
catastrophic thinking was decreased that
sort of thing the reason I think we need
to go back to schools is because the
effects were much larger and there were
more of them in people 25 and under than
in the older population so now imagine
that I'm VSCO GE and you're my head of
HR what should we do differently what
should we do to implement your new
practices well i think i would first
assess where you are as an organization
if they're you know what and whether you
use flourishing scale or whether
using some other scale some easy some
easily measure thing that does something
that measures psychological assets I
think it's really important for people
not to be looking for pathology so not
to be measuring symptoms but looking for
psychological assets and then most
people probably do it if if they feel
safe so like my boss isn't going to see
the results and they don't like a
logical test as part of my annual just
annually or once sir yeah well we do it
annually oh and and everybody doesn't it
is an online thing you fill out an
online thing you fill out okay and it
has you know we have about eighty seven
to ninety percent people take it
seriously and actually you know the
various ways people look at resolve to
show that they didn't just say see on
every answer and they they had questions
and answers that made sense now the
military I presumed that the results of
those tests are then evaluated by
superiors of various sorts wellness
there's absolutely absolutely it's
anonymous only the person who took see
who took the survey sees his personal
result there is however we do dump that
assign it a surrogate identifier and
then combine it with the other thing so
for example PT test scores and
promotions and and the various uniform
couldn't military justice things drug
use so we can tell so because we want to
be able to show that that a
psychologically healthy people have
fewer of those bad things and we show
that you know people are psychologically
doing well are more likely to be
promoted and go to the War College
that sort of thing and so so people
those are that fact those facts are
widely available now and so everybody
can see that hmm if I were more
psychologically fit I would be more
likely to do well so there's some
incentive to doing well it's not to
mention the fact that that you'll
consume less health care so the notion
is that the consumer this to consumers
they kind of is statistically anonymize
a consumer on the organization level
than the individual themselves see their
own scores and if the score is not what
they want to be there's there's
something you can do about it yes and
there's and you take the assessment and
you get an individualized plan of what
we recommend it you know it's an
algorithmically derived plan of what we
think you should do which courses you
should take some things to improve and
so you're welcome to do it or not do it
again I'm GE and so along with this I
need to train in the same way you had a
train to drill sergeant yeah we have to
train our managers and the same way that
you had programs available to people if
they wanted him or if there's test Frank
results suggest they could use them did
the corporation would have to provide
that as well right is this what you're
doing with with tech works pretty much
and it's a software company ah yeah say
um software yes but more it does a lot
of different things ok it's still early
presumably the results of the products
have not yet been released but but
that's kind of where you're going you
know I do think at the civilian life
being full of traumas of various sources
adverse effects events i'll try to stick
to the terminology but a lot of us
receive them as traumas because we're
not we haven't learned to avoid the
scarring if you will in your performance
review at work of poor performance
review or something like that is it
simply a matter of sitting down of
understanding that there's a better way
to internalize this sitting down with
someone and understanding how to sort of
extract the positive lessons it's a two
you know two three four or five meetings
and you're there or does it take a
lifetime of work well I think I think
understanding what happens you know so
let's say you you um you're sitting down
talking your boss and you get not the
evaluation you were hoping for
you can internalize that and you can go
back and say I'm stupid I'm I'm not I
might cut out for this that doesn't lead
to any that if you believe that if you
believe it's a global problem it's me
that doesn't leave to you doing anything
purposeful to change it because it's
hopeless if you say I could have shown
up on work on time more frequently if
that was one of the complaints about you
if it says that you know I could have in
fact not not been using the work
computer when it wasn't lunchtime I mean
so if there are specific things that
your boss said about you that you could
if you focus on the individual things
that you could have done differently
then you can change and you can improve
and so one of the big things we teach is
that that things are local not global
and a particular time frame as opposed
to forever you know you get dumped by
your boyfriend that doesn't mean you're
unlovable or ugly that means that you
and that guy aren't going to get along
forever and you know there's whatever
that there's seven billion people
there's three and a half billion more
guys so you know you could probably find
another one you were constitutionally
inclined this way I think you told me
that you that you've never really had a
trauma in your life that you've from the
youngest age they would turn these you
know whatever didn't kill you made you
stronger and etc so we I mean I'm gonna
argue that it was easier for you than
for some because you're just kind of an
optimistic glass half-full sort of
person take someone middle-aged who's
had who feels scarred who feels
traumatized by life can you turn them
around I believe that you can I believe
that's what cognitive behavioral therapy
does hmm we just you you know we use it
preventively so that people can practice
those same techniques on small
challenges so that when you get faced
with a really big one um it it's more
it's easier to do but that's true about
any kind of thing you want to learn I
mean we don't we don't wait until
there's a crisis we don't wait until
someone is shooting at you in the Army
before we teach you to shoot back we
kind of send you to the range first and
we give you a lesson then we let you
stand up
and then we have a live-fire exercise
where there's somebody sort of shooting
over your head you're shooting back so
so we don't wait till there's a crisis
and then all of a sudden say we're going
to have you know just-in-time learning
so that works for some things but it
doesn't work really well to think that
you need to be using every day so I
think we need to apply that same kind of
thinking I mean I didn't learn I didn't
learn to stop on plug you know to stop
the bleeding they order the first time
somebody made a hole-in-one I'm going to
kind of learned that technique before I
got there can you give an example of a
little thing that demonstrates what
you're talking about something that
somebody could learn in midlife makes it
an example that an adverse effect that
an adverse event rather that you could
you could focus on as they kind of a
baby step towards this process sure an
adverse event an adult would be you
applied for a promotion and didn't get
it and so it's not like you know you're
going to starve to death or it just
means that you didn't now you're not
going to be able to to you know buy
whatever it was you were planning to do
with the excess money you made so so we
would we would you know work kind of
through that and what can you do
differently to to increase a likelihood
that will happen next time so lesson
number one is don't kept aastra
catastrophize rank and number two turn
it into a in action plan saurian so if
you feel guilty if you feel embarrassed
if you feel something if you have those
negative emotions you're sad then then
we like to tell people that you should
if that should lead the purposeful
action to change it one last question on
the data front if the world adopts this
this technique and we start a giving
people you know these exams or at least
giving them the opportunity to take
these exams and be taking the data and
learning from an anonymized etc what do
you think we'll do differently as a
society in terms of our health care
policy are our internal corporate
culture or HR policies you name it well
I think we're going to have to do what
we did in the military which is attack
it in all levels in my case that was a
forester level that's
star level the two star level the
sergeant level but in our society it's
going to have to be education the
compensation schemes you know when we
compensate people monetarily for
continuing to have symptoms that doesn't
exactly incentivize you to get better so
we have different systems we heard it
several times in the last day about
about we've attacked this from a data
standpoint we haven't attacked it from a
governmental policy standpoint and I
think that an if we don't do that it's
going to be very difficult to implement
this across our society I'm going to
take em one question from Twitter if I
if I have time are there any gender
differences in resilience we did not
find any using a global assessment which
we had intended to be to be
gender-neutral we really didn't find any
differences now I couldn't tell you
whether that means we were really
successful at making it or that women in
the military are more like men but we
didn't find any differences and the one
actually it was one other good question
i want to squeeze in here we talked
about teaching and we talked about books
you could read do you find day is there
a preferred method is it do you think it
should be taught or can it be learned
simply by studying these methods online
or in books well what i can say is that
there hasn't been any any significant
randomized control trials of learning it
by a book or or online that shows it was
effective that doesn't mean it isn't
depends depends are all taught we're all
taught and I think the communication and
relationship building is one of the
things that's important but whether or
not it can be done using gaming I mean
it may well be we just there there isn't
any evidence that it is yet possibly an
opportunity for your new clan
opportunity to excel for someone and
possibly is something your new company
rules and who now has something to do
with who knows alright thank you and
join me a thing
I